euromaxx highlights and here's your host
Louise Houghton hello and welcome to our
highlight so let's power straight in
with a look at what we have in store
body and soul performers artists turn
themselves into human sculptures music
mania we bring you the glam rock at the
world air guitar championships and city
cinematography moms in Belgium is
artistically documenting their streets
Richard Shatner is one of the leaders in
performance studies his theories lie in
the concept that if one person is
watching another then there is a
performance the movement is the name of
a performance art festival that took
place in the Swiss city of beale this
August one of the groups there didn't
even move during their artistic displays
and yet spectators couldn't take their
eyes off their creative forms
Lynn neelam has been rolling through
bill for almost two hours the Chinese
performer is merciless with his own body
this group is quietly inhibiting the
dynamic flow of pedestrian traffic
everywhere visitors to the city are
confronted with the human form
performers in the midst of bills public
spaces living sculptures
we want people to see our bodies moving
in public urban space we want people to
come and like really look at public
space and see it differently with these
bodies with these dancing bodies these
moving bodies still bodies sculptures
made up of human bodies have been
integrated into the city's architecture
they lead the eye of the beholder to
places that usually don't attract much
attention developed by Austrian
choreographer Villa Donna the project is
called bodies in urban spaces
it's giving it our own theme for me it's
about finding positions that somehow
sees your attention and you need the
power of humanity to do that eventually
kick off this is me calling attention to
our very fragile bodies is also
important to me the man shows a human
being was on the one hand very flexible
and able to adjust yeah juxtaposed with
the hard unyielding architecture of the
city Donna takes a playful approach to
the urban world he has a good eye for
cityscape locations that can be turned
into backdrops for friction and conflict
the choreographers set up the route the
performance takes weeks ago
the final form a sculpture takes depends
on the artistic abilities of the
performers that Dona has cast for each
location he and Estella lead the eight
performers at this location correspond
to the eight cubes they're lying
crosswise diagonally to the stairs and
the solidity of the cube which is a very
static element this will face the
choreographer rolled out the project for
the first time eight years ago it has
since appeared in many cities in Europe
the US and asia septa castle practice
via yahoo took around three or four
years and during this time we fine-tuned
to the format and all its elements
that's why it took so much time its head
to keep the hold up i but now the work
is finished and it can be performed in
different urban contexts in fish eat
alone I'd love to take it to China or
Africa that would be interesting with
mr. yeah maybe we will I flick out akina
gained as well nothing to the sound of a
contestar
living sculptures that disperse after
just a few minutes and reappear in a new
post somewhere else groups of spectators
follow the route to the city seeing it
with fresh eyes I find it very
interesting because they are giving life
to spaces that we normally don't pay
attention to I find it very impressive
because it blends into the city so well
although the clothes also make it very
colorful lazuli I like to play on
architecture the buildings and shapes
also the flexibility of the performers
and the energy that it gives to the
spectator the next week said then I
don't you forget excerpts from 50 years
of performance art on the streets of
Beale
and when the performances blend
seamlessly into the urban environment
the lines between art and everyday life
vanish well from subtle performances
like those to what some might think are
crazy performances on stage we were at
the world air guitar championships to
see competitors giving it their all in
the hopes of winning this year's title
the best our guitarists from 16
countries are competing in oulu finland
for the title of world champion each of
them has 60 seconds to impress the jury
a weird hobby but very entertaining
at that night they're really straight
I'm from Australia so I've never seen it
before runtastic even shortly before the
finale the excited participants receive
instructions on the stage and have a
chance to rehearse Sabrina sean is here
representing Germany this will be the 23
year olds first international
performance she's brought along her
parents and friends from Bavaria to
support her instead of two just now I
was standing on the stage and saw how
big it is and how many people the room
will hold I feel really queasy I don't
know what to do but I'm also looking
forward to it a bit when the song starts
I'll forget my nervousness I hope so
anyway Shrum Elias Lady Liberty is a
rarity in the scene most air guitarists
our mail only two women have become
world champion in the last 18 years
one of them is alena vest file from
Germany known as the devil's nice she
won the title in 2011 this year she'll
perform in oulu out-of-competition hems
fella by the inhibition threshold is
very high in playing air guitar and I
think men have fewer problems overcoming
their inhibitions women always want to
look good and be pretty and you simply
can't when you play air guitar when you
make weird faces your hair goes every
which way you scream you stand in
ludicrous positions lots of women say I
wouldn't dare do that but that's exactly
what's great about it it's so liberating
it really clears your head high and
smash I've also Shabazz's posted in cups
I anyone hoping to be crowned world
champion must exude charisma while
imitating real guitar picking finish
rock guitarist you hot or villain has
been on the jury since 1996 why convey
school Maria even though there are five
different jurors well we're usually all
in agreement about who should win and
all your think it's the same with the
audience it's hard to say what makes for
a winner it's not your standard
competition with exacting criteria it's
just something you feel in your heart
let you down the court already in the
first round to the candidates perform
songs they prepared in advance the jury
awards them anywhere from four to six
points the best ten make it into the
second round in which they all have to
improvise to the same song two Americans
were seen as the favorites going in mean
Moline from Kansas City is the defending
champ and New Yorker Aristotle thrills
audiences with his comedic talent
sabina schlom gave it her all on stage
and wound up in ninth place
oh cool there's nothing else to say it
was great fun the biggest surprise of
the night was 19 year old Nanami seven
seas nogaro from Japan
she won over the jury with her wild and
technically accomplished performance the
new world champion received an electric
guitar and amp a surprise and Thomas got
to this edge like each year the World
Championship ended with Neil Young song
rockin in the free world then all the
participants jammed together for world
peace
and the winner there potentially enjoyed
a celebratory drink the thought of that
brings us nicely onto the subject of
wines which do you prefer we know of
white red and rosy these days but what
about orange wine this nipple is made
from white grapes but by using an old
fermentation technique you get this
darker color and distinctive taste to
learn more about the process we visited
the grave the vineyard in Italy new
white wines and deep unusual colors have
been dubbed by wine connoisseurs as
orange one or natural wine the Italian
winemaker yashka gröbner is something of
a pioneer in this field but he finds the
term orange rather misleading oh we
classify cornella I don't call myself an
orange winemaker my wine is more amber
colored it's lively it shines people
when a wine is a deep orange color it
means it's on its way out it has passed
its fast vino curve others a molten the
italian term is vini naturally or
natural wine in the northeastern region
of friuli gröbner grows traditional
rebola gianna grapes he harvests only
the best fruit and ferments the grapes
without removing the skin hence the
unusual color Adobe amo partir de una
persona our profit from each vine is low
we pick the grapes very late either in
October or weather permitting in
November support I don't care no them
and then they are fermented in amphoras
an alarm for a
rovner imports these vast handmade
vessels known as amphoras from the
Republic of Georgia in the Caucasus he
took delivery of his first ones 13 years
ago they are dug into the ground and a
grape juice is kept inside for a year
Rob nur learned the old-fashioned method
from Georgian wine makers
he's determined to take a purist
approach without the use of any state of
the art equipment
fermentation a spontaneous in the
amphora the grape juice for mens without
any additives for that is because they
are made of play and kept in the ground
so the temperature remains constant Eric
windy you don't need any fancy cooling
because the conditions are already ideal
own ambiente de la in the restaurant la
subida in the nearby town of hormones
visitors often order orange wife that
served at room temperature mostly with
meat or cheese whoever did I drink it
with foie gras they go very well
together I find the wine has a strong
bouquet but it's still dry process of
input eman SI coupe a mule aviso
bodyguard like to say it has a distinct
aroma i dont matta KU but it's not for
everyone potato potato to persuade some
of the a Michaela piano has been keeping
an eye on the orange wine trend for
years he even has grabbed nurs rebola in
his wine cellar in a wine shop a bottle
like this would cost between 35 and 70
euros it's a niche product and has a
percentage market share ayano says its
quality is really improved
so no home a DVD bianchi exactly they
are white wines that are pressed like
red wines they are fermented with their
skins which creates a range of tastes as
if we were drinking white wine and red
wine at the same time alice is a temple
bureau's grabner sells sixty percent of
his wine in Italy and the rest around
the world after fermentation the wine
matures in wooden casks for six years
with natural wines gaining popularity
Radnor's daughter matea recently joined
the family venture yossi peled acquit
the more we talk about this wine the
more wine makers will go back to natural
methods to make so-called natural wine
more if I think this is good for me and
for wine-growing better Marilyn said
these are new amphoras from Georgia yo
spectrometer will use them to ferment
the entire grape including the seeds
just like they did in centuries past
when staying in southern Europe now as
we head to a wonderful holiday
destination the Greek island of Rhodes
is full of ancient ruins especially in
the old town on the north coast it's
certainly my favorite island out of
those that i visited steeped in greek
mythology has loads of fresh traditional
food and drinks and has a stunning
coastline with more than 300 days of
sunshine on record a year Mandraki
harbor in the city of rhodes sculptures
of allah fina and a la voz the Greek
islands Harold animals welcoming
incoming ships
in ancient times man Jackie was home to
the thirty meter tall Colossus of Rhodes
in 227 bc an earthquake destroyed the
bronze statue which depicted the Sun god
Apollo archaeologist vasilis
Caravaggio's has lived on the island for
more than 30 years and for him Rhodes is
always a journey through history the
Rodians wanted the statute to be rebuilt
the invoice that they sent to the or
lack of a polo or a trove Apollo Apollo
illios apparently in Delphie was
negative the God did not want anything
which was on the ground to be placed
again and so they drafted as it was and
continued to be a place for worship on a
tour through the old town the street of
the Knights leads to the palace of the
Grand Master of the order of st. John
built in the 14th century
the four kilometer long city wall was
built in the middle ages and is well
preserved in 1988 unesco declared the
old town a World Heritage Site the city
was divided into sections they caught
the Knights quarter in the area of the
audience's the citizens after the
occupation by the ottoman sultan
Suleiman the Magnificent 1522 the city
was i mean the audience were expelled
were outside falsely the citizens of
roads were coming in only at sunrise
with a provision Cimino kinds of
products to sell and buy from the market
area and out again before sun sunset
that was it for 400 years to 1912 wasn't
aliens reopened the gate around 50
kilometers south of Road city is the
village of Lindos with its Acropolis
it's typically Greek architecture manor
houses and small lanes attract about 3
million tourists a year lindos is under
a monument protection order cars aren't
allowed in the town centre but you're
allowed to use a donkey
it's a wonderful place I think it's the
most attractive place in modules just
like a picture from from the magazine
when you want allocation and you'll see
that over here it's really beautiful
stereotype of krrish I think yeah this
is what I expected from it there are
three small beaches at lindos the best
is st. paul's bay which is at the back
of Lindos sambuca beach is a bit less
romantic but it's great for long walks
if you're looking for something a bit
quieter the southern half of the island
may be better suited to you
perhaps after some sunbathing you'd like
to cool off so why not try petal Otis
the valley of the butterflies between
june and july there are also millions of
moths because it's cool and damp after
the mating season they fly back to the
southern side of the island yeah Lots
ready hope it's still peaceful yes yes
and the best and deep well the mops and
they are just so amazing this is a one
of the best things to see here in others
it's completely different from other
things that you can see here because
it's cool and it's a lot of butterflies
Smith happening oh you can see hundreds
of butterflies here if you have an eye
for detail you can discover more and
more and the kids think it's great supa
back in the city of roads just off the
tourist trail and the District of New
Hardy is the Coco's restaurant the chef
your gates le gasp is preparing yevette
see a greek specialty lamb stew with
onions tomatoes fresh olive oil garlic
and rice noodles
the lamb needs to cook for around 40
minutes at 180 degrees Celsius in a
traditional wood oven this gives the
meet a very special flavor
it's worth trying because your vet see
as the typical flavor of the island of
Rhodes well from Greece we head to moms
in Belgium as the city is already
preparing to be a European Capital of
Culture next year the title gives mons
the chance to better establish itself
and generate cultural social and
economic benefits in 2015 they'll be
hosting a vast number of projects and
events based on Belgium and European
culture and one of these is an artistic
alternative to google maps street view
we were there to see them film Mons in
Belgium is putting itself on a new map
this time with the help of two French
artists from the theatre group X TNT so
purpose of the project is to create a
map of moose which will be European
cultural capital ready next year so
we're creating this map with a Street
View application so we are going filming
shooting 10 kilometers of the streets
with the inhabitants which is very
important in an artistic cassette a 360
degrees stop motion camera captures the
images the actors for this scene are all
local residents including the police
it's my town so for me it's important
and
and we are having fun so it's okie the
artists in charge of street review
specialize in attention-grabbing urban
actions
these scenes represent a police chase of
sorts
once the action has been filmed the team
quickly moves on to the next
installation the director of the project
has a certain message in mind the idea
too is this this project was well one
day i was just googling my street in
multi close to paris and I was seeing
how ugly it was how ugly the people were
how looked like a phantom phantom city
and the more I looked into all these
streets the more I thought but who does
these streets belong to they belong to
the people we're playing with the people
we're getting the people to come down
the street and to express through
different concepts different ideas their
own feeling about how they should just
represent their city in a more playful
way playful indeed this action involves
leaving the office behind and getting
closer to nature the results are
somewhat surreal
the idea is to fill up the city and try
to get as much of the interesting parts
of the city so today we're gonna do a
lil of where the Bazar Museum of moles
is and the name of the museum is the BAM
the BAM will host three major
exhibitions next year including one by
Dutch artist Vincent van Gogh today's
urban action in front of the museum
involves two groups supporters of
classic artists like Bruegel and Renoir
and other famous names and those who
adore Andy Warhol what looks like a
confrontation is just an enthusiastic
expression for art
while some of the local residents
observe the action others seem confused
by what's going on
most will host some 300 projects as
european capital of culture main
destinations will be the Grom class the
city's main square and the belfry tower
a world heritage site mom's dates back
to the Middle Ages but many of the
current buildings were constructed
between the 15th and 17th centuries it's
an easygoing town steeped in history but
the city is eager to promote itself as a
place which also embraces modern life
back in front of the museum the street
view scenes are slowly gaining momentum
ludovic a former stage director has to
keep everyone focused on the action
filming goes late into the evening and
when it's over it will be on to the next
scene that will help months put its
stamp on European culture in 2015
and I'm sure we'll be bringing you more
from moms in the coming year right now
though it is time to say goodbye so
until I'm back in the studio again take
care of yourselves and as we say here in
Germany cheese